so much for joining us and let us begin
straight away with the Olympics a global
display of the world's greatest athletes
and also dressage I don't care if you're
your horse but you are not getting
a medal for the fall plane that the
build-up to the real games has been
turbulent with Brazil experiencing a
massive recession protests in the
streets and a Zika outbreak but on
Friday
NBC urged us to forget all that and
focus on the opening ceremony the
Cariocas
as they call themselves they are ready
at least for tonight to put the
headlines aside hit the reset button and
throw one massive party did somebody say
party oh no oh no arms holder got into
the cap Aranea supply everybody watch
yourself she gets grabby ceremony itself
was as spectacular as you'd expect
featuring everything from fireworks to
those little scooters from junior high
gym class to people throwing IKEA flag
and lamp shade at each other two plants
forming the Olympic rings before having
a full-on plant gasm if people in that
stadium start giving birth to palm trees
in nine months you will know why the
ceremony also featured a solemn moment
of history she is one of brazil's most
recognizable exports
she walks on her country's biggest stage
that is supermodel Gisele Bundchen
putting to everything we have heard this
will be Giselle's last calf off wait
wait
lost catwalk what's happening to her oh
my god they're gonna kill Gisele are
they or maybe they'll send her we're all
supermodels go a farm upstate where they
can Satterlee walk around and graze on
tiny amounts of grass still the
centerpiece of any opening ceremony is
the parade of Nations that inspirational
moment where athletes from around the
globe come together as one to have Today
Show anchors point out everything that's
wrong with their countries as Turkey
enters the stadium there's got to be so
many mixed emotions there was an
attempted coup in July that kills open
for the government it's been a difficult
and tragic year foreign tourists attacks
in Paris in Nice and Normandy she was in
Katmandu for the national championship
last year when the devastating
earthquake hit that region that killed
an estimated 9,000 people Sudan is
entering the stadium troubled nation
holy it is a good thing that those
anchors don't behave like that during
the Macy's Day Parade there go shrek
obviously jaundiced and beset by weight
problems stemming from chronic diabetes
here's Charlie Brown clearly losing his
fight with leukemia and finally there is
Snoopy who of course is going to be put
down later today but that might honestly
be preferable to whenever they tried to
get jocular instead once every four
years someone gets to say it and today
it's my turn so how about this
check out Djibouti
we did it I did it yeah you did
I mean Djibouti is a country with a rich
cultural history and a multi-ethnic
population of over 850,000 people but
you are right it does also sound like
her but now the parade itself was a
fairly standard affair as always most
country's athletes were forced to dress
like flight attendants from shitty
Airlines with one absolutely glorious
exception oh wow
we'll just sit here for a minute he's so
shiny what is that it just became a
sensation in Brazil tell you that they
love him here as demerit opinon
what's not to love it's a great athlete
mmm I think Meredith and Hoda just did
whatever those trees did earlier look we
might be remixed to gloss over the fact
that there is real political turmoil in
Brazil right now their president Dilma
Rousseff has been suspended since May
following corruption allegations and did
not attend the opening ceremony saying
imagine you're going to throw a party
you work on it for years you set it all
up and then on the day of the party
someone shows up takes your place and
takes over your party in this story of
the games I am for Cinderella which is
absolute
not least because Cinderella did not
organize the ball the prince's publicist
Andrea did to distract from the gay
rumors surrounding the prince come on
think about it the guest list was every
eligible maiden it was Cinderella or
Katie Holmes please please it was
obvious now instead Brazil's current
acting president Michel temer was there
although he too is not exactly beloved
acting president Michel temer declaring
the games officially open but greeted by
jeers those boos actually make sense for
a couple of reasons first he's unelected
and is planning to push through a number
of austerity measures and second he's a
poet who once released a book of poetry
titled anonymous intimacy featuring this
actual poem of red fiery flames of fire
brilliant eyes which smile with scarlet
lips fires they take hold of me of my
mind my soul or mine in heat my body on
fire consumes dissolved finally ashes
are left that I spread on the bed to
sleep now what is interesting about that
poem is nothing but what
relevant about it is that his muse is
his wife Marcella who is 42 years
younger than him he is 75 she is 33 and
I'll say this
at least 170 something American
politicians get creepily handsy with
30-something women they have the decency
to do so with their own daughters it
gets one step worse because she
apparently has a tattoo of his name on
her neck which seems like a tradition
that is part of a wedding ceremony and a
sin your frogs now does any of this have
anything to do with the Olympics no but
did I just find out about it and needs
to tell somebody yes absolutely
absolutely but but for all of this the
Olympic Games promise to be genuinely
inspiring for the first time a team of
refugees will be competing under the
Olympic flag one of them is yousra
martini an 18 year old sealing refugee
who helps keep the boat carrying her and
a group of others afloat when its engine
failed of the Greek Coast she's pretty
incredible just listen to her describe
her training regime in Syria sometimes
you couldn't train because of the war or
sometimes you had a training and there
is a bumping in the swimming pool so it
was there you can see like the roof
there is three or four places is open
when you have a problem in your life
that doesn't mean you have to sit around
and cry like babies or something okay
buzz
I'm almost
very impressed by that woman and second
when something goes wrong I don't cry
like a baby I felt like a grown man and
I'll tell you why it's louder it
terrified strangers and no one comforts
me it's better I will say this though
there was one moment in the opening
ceremony this week where the
inspirational rhetoric went just a touch
too far in this Olympic world there is
one universal law for everybody in this
Olympic world we are all equal okay
that is simply not true if that were the
case you wouldn't need to have an
Olympics the whole reason we do this is
to find out who is better than everyone
else so that we can make them stand
higher than the other people who are not
as good as there because the point of
the game is not to celebrate equality it
is to celebrate individuals excellence
so let us all settle in for two
incredible weeks of celebrating the
fittest the bravest the most beautiful
and of course the drunkest of us all did
somebody say party